an exciting monetary Innovation was the
invention of Bitcoin in 2009. Bitcoin is
a decentralized digital currency also
known as a cryptocurrency
ethereum and Dogecoin are two other
examples of cryptocurrencies
the Allure of cryptocurrencies is
twofold first there are digital asset
that can be transferred electronically
and securely using cryptographic methods
without a physical object changing hands
as is the case with paper currency
second cryptocurrencies are not created
by a central bank or government
the decentralized nature of the
cryptocurrency can make them an
attractive alternative in countries
whose central banks have a bad
reputation for printing too much
currency resulting in high inflation
that wipes out the purchasing power of
money
critics of cryptocurrencies often point
to a third aspect for their popularities
cryptocurrencies can be transferred
outside of the financial system and away
from legal and tax scrutiny
in the early Incarnation could
currencies such as Bitcoin have
fluctuated a great deal in value
Bitcoin went from about 600 in December
2013 to about nineteen thousand eight
hundred dollars in December 2017 back to
three thousand three hundred dollars in
December 2018 before climbing into the
sixty thousand dollar range in 2021 and
then falling back into the twenty
thousand dollar range in 2022. at its
peak market value all Bitcoins combined
were worth over one trillion dollars
roughly the M1 of Canada or Australia
these big spectacular increases
paradoxically make cryptocurrencies less
likely to serve as money rather than as
a speculative asset
paper currencies like the Zimbabwe
dollar that are not good stores of value
become less useless mediums of Exchange
but for cryptocurrencies it turns out
that the Allure of being too good as a
store of value can also lead it to
becoming less used as a medium of
Exchange
for example a cryptocurrency called the
shiba inu was created in 2020 based on
an internet meme
despite its Origins as a satirical
cryptocurrency amazingly the value of
the Sheba currency boomed in 2021
increasing three hundred and thirty
thousand fold between January and
December
so one hundred dollars worth of Sheba
Inu coins purchased in January of 2021
would have been worth 33 million dollars
in December of 2021.
why would anyone ever use Shiba Inu
coins to buy a pair of shoes they would
be much better off holding the coin and
cashing it in later
it should be said that not all
cryptocurrencies are as volatile as the
Shiba Inu so-called stable coins such as
tether are cryptocurrencies that are
tied in value to an existing paper
currency and in theory backed by
reserves of traditional currency so
volatility alone will not determine
whether the use of cryptocurrencies
increases over time
regardless of whether cryptocurrencies
will ever supplant paper currency it is
clear that central banks have taken a
keen interest in the rise of electronic
currency
central banks who control the supply of
fiat currency are thus considering and
in some case issuing their own
electronic money that can be used by
individuals in the economy
let's return to fiat currency and focus
a little bit more on the Federal Reserve
or the FED as it is known in popular
parlance which is served as the Central
Bank of the United States since it was
established in 1913
the Federal Reserve has two arms the
Board of Governors located in Washington
DC consists of seven people appointed to
non-renewable 14-year terms by the
president of the United States and then
confirmed by the Senate
one of those governors is appointed by
the president as chairman of the board
in addition to the Board of Governors
there are 12 regional federal reserve
banks distributed around the country
these Banks monitor Local Economic
conditions and act as a bank to banks in
their region effectively they process
checks facilitate electronic payments
between Banks and also act as overseers
of the banks in the district
the key decision maker with regard to
the money supply is the Federal Open
Market Committee or fomc which consists
of the seven members of the Board of
Governors the president of the New York
fed and four rotating presidents of the
FED Regional Banks
the fomc meets about eight times per
year
these meetings and the subsequent policy
decisions are among the most anticipated
economic events of the year
at these meetings the fomc decides
whether to change the supply of money
and by how much in order to achieve its
monetary policy goals for the U.S
economy
those goals were laid out by Congress as
being to quote promote maximum
employment and stable prices in the U.S
economy unquote
the actions of the FED to increase the
supply of money are transmitted to the
economy via Banks
the FED plays a critical role in the
banking sector both to protect the
stability of the financial system as
well as the soundness of individual
financial institutions
to this End the Fed uses several tools
banks are typically required to keep a
certain fraction of their customers
deposits at the Federal Reserve this
fraction is known as the required
Reserve ratio
banks are also allowed to borrow money
from the FED if they need money for some
reason such as an unexpected increase in
customer withdrawals
the rate of interest at which the FED
lends money to Banks is known as the
discount rate
Banks act as Financial intermediaries
between Savers and depositors people who
want to earn interest on the money they
do not intend to use currently for
consumption and investors and borrowers
people who are willing to pay interest
to borrow money to undertake spending or
invest in projects that they do not
currently have enough funds for
Banks make money by charging investors
and borrowers a higher interest rate
than they pay to the Savers and
depositors
a simple balance sheet can illustrate
the behavior of a typical Bank
the bank's liabilities are its deposits
money that belongs to its customers and
its debt money that belongs to its
creditors
the bank's assets are the loans it has
made to clients or to other Banks and
any Financial Security such as stocks
and bonds it holds and its reserves
which refers to deposits that the bank
chooses to hold on to rather than
lending out or investing in securities
reserves can be held either in the
bank's own Vault called Vault cash or at
the central bank
so in essence we think of the Central
Bank as a bank to Banks a place where
Banks can put money into their accounts
these reserves can take the form of
required reserves which are the fraction
of deposits that the FED mandates that
Banks hold
however banks will sometimes hold more
than what is required of them at the FED
these are called excess reserves
in this example the bank holds one
billion dollars in deposits and owes 250
million dollars to its creditors so it's
total liabilities are 1.25 billion
dollars
it has 700 million dollars worth of
loans that it has made to others and
owns 550 million dollars worth of stocks
and bonds and has decided to hold no
reserves in excess of the required
reserves which are 10 of its deposits so
100 million dollars
the difference between assets and
liabilities is what is known as Bank
Capital essentially if the bank were to
be folded up today Bank Capital
represents what would be left over for
the shareholders and the owners of the
bank after all its assets are sold off
and all its liabilities paid off
Bank Capital represents the initial
Capital that owners put into the bank
plus any operating profits that the bank
has retained over the years
when you read about a bank failing what
it means is that its capital has fallen
to below zero its liabilities exceed its
assets
when that happens The Regulators will
shut down the bank and transfer its
assets and liabilities to another bank
while making sure that depositors are
made hope
in normal times the FED changes the
money supply in one of three ways
the primary way and by far the most
common in the United States is by using
open market operations buying or selling
government bonds
If the Fed wants to increase the money
supply it will inject money into the
financial system to buy government bonds
If the Fed wants to decrease the money
supply it will sell government
securities from its existing collection
in exchange for cash and pull that money
out of the financial system
why U.S government bonds well they
represent a safe asset that the FED can
buy hold and sell without worrying about
substantial price fluctuations in the
underlying asset value
a second way to change the money supply
is by changing the discount rate that
the FED charges banks in exchange for
Lending Banks money
by lowering the discount rate the FED
can make it easier for banks to borrow
money from the Fed
this increased borrowing leads to more
money circulating in the economy
conversely a higher discount rate will
make it more costly for banks to borrow
from the fed this decrease borrowing
leads to less money circulating in the
economy
finally and probably in the least common
way if the FED wants to raise the supply
of money it can lower the required
Reserve ratio which will permit Banks to
keep fewer Reserves at the fed and allow
them to make more loans which will
increase the amount of money circulating
in the economy
for example on March 15 2020 the FED
reduced reserve requirements to zero
conversely If the Fed wants to lower the
supply of money it can raise the
required Reserve ratio this forces Banks
to keep more Reserves at the fed and
reduces the amount of loans they can
make which reduces the amount of money
circulating in the economy
to understand the role that Banks play
in the money creation process
let's think of an example where the
Federal Reserve decides to inject 100
million dollars into the economy via an
open market operation
for Simplicity let's just suppose that
the FED buys government bonds directly
from the bank whose balance sheet we
highlighted although the analogy will
hold even if the purchases were through
a series of banks
in effect the FED puts a hundred million
dollars into the bank's Reserve account
at the FED in exchange for the bonds the
bank's Holdings of financial securities
Fall by 100 million dollars from 550
million to 450 million dollars
and it's excess reserves reserves held
above and beyond what it is required to
hold rise from zero to a hundred million
dollars
the bank has to now make a decision
about how to use these additional
Reserves
notice that the open market operation
did not change the bank's Financial
Health that is its capital did not
change
nor did it impact how much reserve the
bank was required to hold still required
to hold 10 percent of deposits
so the bank is free to lend out its
additional reserves rather than keeping
them in excess results earning little to
no interest
when Banks lend out the reserves the
supply of money in the economy increases
however things may not always work as
neatly as I describe when there's
turmoil in the financial markets and in
the biking sector
for instance in bad times Banks may
become more concerned about making loans
to customers and may hold on to excess
reserves instead of lending all the new
deposits out
this means that the FED would need a
larger open market operation to achieve
its goals
if you open a typical principles of
economics textbook that is the sort of
discussion you are very likely to find
within its pages
and yet the way the FED has operated
over the years since 200809 does not fit
neatly into the story just described
Jane Eric and Scott Waller two
economists at the Federal Reserve have
done a lot of public education work
trying to get instructors to acknowledge
that this particular textbook model no
longer works
at the end of December 2021 Banks held
almost 4 trillion dollars in reserves at
the Fed
even though since the march of 2020 the
Federal Reserve has no longer required
Banks to hold Reserves
this sharp increase in excess reserves
began after the global financial crisis
in 200809 as we see in this chart
irigenwala categorized this period as
one of ample reserves in this world the
FED has less ability to change the money
supply in the economy using traditional
open market operations
intuitively when banks have so much
excess reserves the FED can't impact
their willingness to lend by adding
liquidity into the system
how did this world come about
well to understand this we want to think
about what happened in 200809 when the
housing market imploded and many banks
fell into financial difficulty because
loans and assets related to the housing
market plummeted in value
when an asset Falls in value holding
liabilities fixed the bank's Capital
Falls
let's look at an example suppose we take
our bank after the open market operation
and assume that it also suffered a 10
loss on its assets
notice that the bank's Capital has
shrunk to 30 million dollars
and if the capital shrinks even more the
bank becomes more wary of Lending the
bank becomes more likely to hold on to
the excess reserves rather than risk
making more loans into the housing
market or investing in financial assets
that can fall in value
furthermore the FED helped Banks reduce
some of their uncertainty by offering to
buy up financial securities that Banks
were reluctant to hold
in such a world Banks quickly become
Awash in reserves and the FED is unable
to influence the amount of money
circulating in the economy simply by
using open market operations because
reserves are not a scarce resource the
FED has to adapt to this world of ample
Reserves
we will explore how the FED conducts
policy in such an environment in another
lecture
for now keep in mind that both the
Federal Reserve and the banking sector
play a critical role in how money the
vital lifeblood of the economy is
created and distributed throughout the
economy
if you think of money as the lifeblood
of the economy then the FED is the
beating heart that pumps the blood and
banks are the veins and arteries that
transport the money to the economy
over the last decade we have witnessed
dramatic changes in how money is defined
created and used within the economy
new technologies that allow payment with
mobile devices have gained ground not
only in rich countries like the United
States with venmo and PayPal but even
more in countries where credit card use
is not as widespread like China with
alipay and WeChat India with imps and
Kenya with m-pesa
the creation of Bitcoin and the recent
upsurge and volume and value of
cryptocurrencies have made clear that
digital currencies will be at least one
component of money in the future
at the same time the Federal Reserve was
creating unprecedented amounts of M1 in
the economy as they dealt with the
economic troubles emanating from the
global financial crisis of 2008.
these problems lingered for a decade and
were soon replaced by a new global
economic shock in the form of the
covid-19 pandemic
during this 15-year period the Federal
Reserve has purchased over 7 trillion
dollars of assets
in other words over seven trillion
dollars worth of reserves have been
introduced into the banking sector
in the next lecture we will examine the
implications of this unprecedented
expansion in the money supply money will
never cease its grip on our fascination
[Music]
thank you